[Music]
all right people
we're alive on the YouTube and we are
officially kicking off Ruben report
YouTube week in partnership with library
today joining me today is a satirist a
guy who is booted off the Twitter and a
guy just trying to make people sane
again yeah I totally I'm just trying to
make people happy again D King nice to
meet you David good to be nice to meet
you we just met in the last like five
minutes it's true we have up you know
it's funny I watch I've been following
you for a while yeah been following you
for a while I've been seeing your stuff
you seem like a guy that you could
easily just spit into my city I can fit
into your city you're on your fair city
of Montreal absolutely yeah absolutely I
haven't been there for about 15 or 20 I
know and we were talking a bit about it
but but yeah it's it's it's definitely
displayed extensively into my identity
online and just throughout you know yeah
yeah well I'm looking forward to this
now we're kicking off YouTube week with
you okay but in there's something kind
of funny happening here because this is
the the first show of YouTube week
today's Monday we're doing five shows in
five days I've already shot the other
five [ __ ] house
so you're the last one that I'm doing
but you're the first one airing and
we're doing it live I have to say the
others were quite spectacular so you're
under a lot of pressure that's okay I'm
pretty sure it'll be fine it'll be fine
we'll be good and I had a lot of steam
you just make me laugh people love to
laugh people love to laugh you can if
you can throw a joke my way I'm gonna
laugh and everyone's gonna be like I
this is the best episode there is a joke
or two in here somewhere I feel like we
can get some emotion at you for sure a
smiley guy you're an emotional guy you
like to yell I mean I sounds I like to I
like to yell so long as I know it's
gonna be like it's gonna turn into a
joke I don't want to yell at people I
feel like everyone's yelling yeah
everyone's yelling I mean listen you're
present on Twitter how cousin would you
say you're on Twitter to present I would
say to imagine yeah to present what do
you mean present by in the moment yeah
in the moment yeah well I'm very in the
moment on Twitter but you know you've
been booted from Twitter yeah oh you
were in that exclusive group oh wait
let's pause for a sec before we go to
that okay I'll try to do a little
research just about your background and
a little you know a little family stuff
and that kind of thing
really I could not you tryna docks me I
was gonna no it's good yeah I'm gonna
have my guys release it while we're
doing that's great
I couldn't find a tremendous amount
about you so give me give me a little
bit about your history and that kind of
thing okay so you want me to start that
you want me to start with my my mom my
dad stuff like that
mom dad sure growing up education that
kind of thing yeah well my dad he he
grew up in a region of India called
Madhya Pradesh and and he grew up in a
town called Jabbar pool and he grew up
with a silver spoon in his mouth he was
a his his father was in his grandfather
actually was in the British Navy he was
a doctor
and he served in the First World War and
the Afghan war and I for the longest
time thought it was the first world war
in the second world war but it's
actually first world war Afghan war and
and yeah he so he is pretty much living
on land that was granted to him by the
by the by by the British yeah and so my
dad had a pretty nice upbringing he went
to British schools English education you
know Catholic education on top of that
like you really just all around my
mother was a national like we're just
gonna skip over my mom my mom grew up in
poverty right so she had to really kind
of climb the ranks and she ended up
becoming a national field hockey coach
in India and yeah yeah she was on her
way to really becoming very very
successful and I don't rub my makeup off
ya know it's really good yeah cuz I mean
I look obvious [ __ ] so it's really it's
quite exactly that's it that's it we did
an I'm just I'm literally just the voice
box for the right here guys the voice
box for the right yes yeah I know I'm so
I mean that might you know my dad came
to Canada
and he you know he got his he got his
degree in computer science I came here
to become a systems analyst and he went
back met my mom brought her here and my
mom actually abandoned all her dreams to
pretty much raised me and my sister so
for the longest time I didn't truly that
didn't click with me and we just I would
say in the last like year year and a
half it really has dawned on me that my
mother sacrificed her entire life to
turn me into the human that I am now
Wow yeah how did you have that moment
with her did she bring it up it wasn't
actually was brought up based on all the
the stuff that I was watching on YouTube
just the this this anti you know like
this whole
just do the anti feminist movement
things like that like things like about
you know how I think one of the things
that really stood out to me was this
this this this fight back against the
traditional woman you know and which i
think is okay I mean I'm cool with women
doing whatever they want to do and they
should they totally should but there's
this there's this beautiful thing about
about a woman that wants to be a mother
a woman that wants to take care of her
kids a woman wants to take care of the
home it just it's so there's so much
value in it right and the amount of
sacrifice that it requires so I got to
really appreciate that about my mom so
yes that and it's kind of funny I mean
without going too deep into feminism
specifically it's kind of funny how this
is flipped right like yeah taking care
of the home and the family and all that
is sort of looked down upon in a weird
way by modern feminism my mom worked
before she had kids then she was a
stay-at-home mom took good care of us
cook meals me after we got to school on
time all of those things was home when
we got home after school and then went
back to work
after when the kids grew up and I think
now that back that like what a cherished
amazing thing that was it is it totally
is and and you know I the the the idea
that I get from a lot of the women that
I interact with is that it's okay it
totally is okay a lot of the stuff that
we talk about is really just present
online it's a lot of these voices online
and because these voices are crazy
they're amplified yeah you know so I
don't get that how do you gauge how much
of its online versus how how much of it
is real before I got into YouTube I was
I'm a fully established person in real
life like I have people I have a network
of people in real life yeah these are
people who I care about these are
friends that I've known for 14 years
like these people who know me way more
than anyone online is ever gonna know me
let me get the straight you exist
outside of I exist outside of the real
friends yeah family and places that you
go and exactly do you eat exactly
incredible I know right isn't it nuts
yeah it's just not so I feel like that
is uh that's a people are a little
contemptuous about that because I
haven't shied away from showing that off
or like being like yeah let's um connect
I know people in real life I was
involved in local politics like that's
the kind of stuff that I kind of try to
do what the hell are we talking about
talking about I know you don't worry
about that let's just keep let's just
keep going here because I think what
we're getting at when we're getting at
best we're I think being part of a full
person is why I like your videos and I
like when you were on Twitter and we're
gonna get to why you're not on Twitter
anymore well I like what you're doing
cuz there's a good mean it's very
obvious now sitting in front of you like
there's just a good nature about you
Thank You sort of like a fullness thank
you and I feel like most people right
now are walking around with like a half
miss you know they're walking around in
this constant state of hating everybody
you're not sure what they think or
they're they're now enemies with family
and friends that two years ago they
weren't yeah and I think what you're
doing is kind of showing people you
could you could smile you can laugh you
can totally smile and laugh yeah cuz I
talk about serious stuff I do I do I I
think that ultimately here's the thing
right I'm privileged right and probably
should be a Canadian alright and and we
don't have the issues that the state of
the states have we really don't we don't
have we you know if a mass shooting were
to happen we were not gonna have people
who are lined up with medical bills that
they can't pay that's something that's
not gonna happen we don't have race
issues to that degree we have a problem
with in terms of how we've treated
Native people in the past but those are
things that where our government is
willing to address or is addressing in a
manner that you know they're addressing
it they're trying to and they're a lot
more empathetic about it right so I have
something I'd like to call you know
Montreal Canadian privilege it's just
something that it's like I grew up in an
environment where it wasn't easy for me
growing up as a kid a brown kid in the
90s but it was I would say a lot easier
for me than it would have been if I was
like in South Chicago South Central LA
or you know Baltimore yeah you know like
I just this it's I have this this I'm
happy because I'm privileged to be happy
yeah it's ultimately yet yeah that's
interesting so you are Sikh which I
think yeah well have no idea I don't
know what he knows about the secret I
know is the Sikhs are inconspicuous like
they're just chillin their chili no need
to push their [ __ ] on anybody I love it
I think well the Sikhs not try to
convert people they I think they
definitely do not try to convert people
they're there to live their lives and I
mean definitely they're down to talk
about it if you want to talk to me like
right now you're but you're talking
about I'll talk to you about it but but
ya know Sikhs and this is a great thing
this is something that nobody talks
about but Sikhs were born out of war
with Islam
and and this was during the Mughal
Empire they were invading India and they
were pretty much converting trying to
get two people to convert or kill them
mm-hmm and nobody wants to talk about
this you know because a lot of people
want to go ahead and say that you know
because it's not nice to say things
about Islam right for some reason you
can say things about Christianity you
could [ __ ] on it all you want
yeah that's it yeah exactly you could
shut up Mormons every was [ __ ] on
Mormons Mormons don't do anything yeah
anyway so anyway so uh so yeah so Sikhs
or Sikhs are interesting because they
were born out of war and and they were
pretty much like almost the first line
of defense against the Muslims when they
were invading and and I'm not saying
like this is this is you know this is
not something that reflects on all
Muslims a hundred percent this is not a
thing that's just it's like I know right
but it but it's people you know I
realized what my culture was that
obviously you know is still around right
Sikhs are still around which means that
at some point they won right and and and
what I've loved about the culture is
that they've been very respectful of
other cultures in the sense that they
are willing to adapt to whatever their
host country is so Sikh Canadians are
very Canadian you know Sikh British
people are very very British you know
and another thing that I find to be
really fascinating is that they don't
have this animosity towards Islam they
don't it's it's very much a very much
religion that from the ground up you're
taught to pretty much be like listen let
bygones be bygones treat things as they
are at the very moment so if something
is happening and you defend yourself
well then you it's fair game yeah but
you know if something happened back in
the day and it's not happening now we're
not gonna hold you hold against you I
don't I don't think about oh my god like
I should be upset at Muslims for what
happened in sixteenth-century yeah you
know that's something else so it goes
back to that be present thing that you
were talking about before right oh yeah
yeah that's is that really why it's so
built-in to you do you think I would say
so I mean listen man I'm telling you
dude I I was not the happiest person for
the longest time um I would say I would
say I would say I spent maybe about like
the last the last
I mean I'm 29 years old I would say I
spent 27 years of my life just being
miserable hmm yeah miserable and I went
through multiple changes for the longest
time I thought I was maybe I want to be
so American so North American so
accepted by by people that I was
becoming someone completely different I
hated the fact that I was brown and and
then eventually that went away and I
realized oh wait wait a minute I'm brown
I don't give a [ __ ] it's great I like my
brown skin I don't give a [ __ ] what's
that like growing up when you're you
know 6 8 15 like what is that how does
that actually come out struggling with
that it was uh I don't know it was weird
it was for me you know one of the things
that I noticed was that was that when I
met other brown people I want to be
friends with them right because I saw
them as allies you know and that's I
think a very normal thing they were like
oh they're brown - I should be friends
with them because they're brown - and
they're like we're in among the sea of
white people but I noticed that a lot of
them would actually kind of like either
want to be they want to be the best
brown person they'd want to be the token
and and that pushed on to me like I want
to be the token as well mm-hmm and I
mean when I was like eight between that
between that period time I would get my
I'll get my ass kicked by this kid
across the street all the time I never
wanted to go outside because any time he
was outside it was gonna be a problem
for me and a lot of it's very like hazy
now because I don't spend too much time
dwelling on my my past in which I was I
felt like a little bit disadvantaged
because it doesn't matter like my past
doesn't matter to that degree
it matters he people love dwelling on
that stuff don't they yeah they love it
sets up the excuse it's literally what
we the reason why we have channels the
reason why we do we do is because people
just spend so much time dwelling on the
past and and I agree the past is
something that needs to be looked at in
reference to regularly you need to look
at the [ __ ] that we did right but it's
it's come to the point now where we're
spelling the password either super proud
of things that you know that have
nothing to do with whatever we just did
right now right or we're just really
pissed off about things that happened to
us back when the people that are alive
today I mean I'm sorry the people that
are alive
have nothing to do with at all and yeah
there's you can go ahead and talk about
how you know like the system is set up
and start such a way and it kind of led
led to this point but like I mean when
you at most of the time when you're
talking to people you're not talking to
a crowd of 1000 people you're talking to
I'm talking to dave rubin right now i'm
not talking to anybody else I mean I
know this bunch of people watching right
now but like we didn't even turn the
cameras on yeah it's okay we just been
talking just been talking that's it we
just it's just it's just you and me yeah
it's the individual level I know they're
like if you if you look at Paul's so you
can look at the individual you have to
look at you'll have to look at
everything you know and that's where
race realists come in and that's where
like all these kind of like these
policies come in right but as human
beings as viewers as content creators we
are not we're not in charge of creating
policies we have to be in charge of
owning our lives and interacting with
people in an authentic way in a way
that's gonna be like you know what I I
you have to care about people I'm not
gonna interact with someone I don't care
about I swear like if there's someone I
look at someone I'm like I don't care
about that [ __ ] person I'm out yeah
if I care about them I'm gonna chill
with them it's just that simple
how did you have that wake up he said 27
years yeah other way what happened I was
trying to be somebody else and then I
realized that myself was good enough and
you know how I realized that it was a it
was I did it ended up dating a girl and
and it was so funny dude just the things
that she would say to me insane like
completely politically incorrect it was
amazing it was incredible was like a
really funny relationship where we just
be able to say whatever the hell we
wanted to each other right and I was
like wait a minute this is what I was
like because back in college I was like
I was like the Van Wilder of my college
I would I stayed around for way too long
yeah I feel way too long I wrote a
column in paper was very politically
incorrect and then at some point I I got
a job at Apple I started becoming very
politically correct I was like you know
what I'm just gonna go say these words
you say these words really really bad or
you and it was very it was political
correctness on a very elementary level
and and then at some point yeah I'm
dating this girl I was like wait a
minute this is the person I need to be
and she really appreciated me for who I
really was cuz I was really myself
around her mmm-hmm I'm gonna burp soon I
apologize you are a decent man you're
giving me a pre apology for a burp yeah
it wouldn't have been necessary yeah
well no it's just so you know it's you I
don't want to burp in front of people
it's like gross you know let me hang out
with Chris Reagan the guy's been burping
all the time he burps a lot he broke up
but you know what it's great it's great
he drinks a lot of Mountain Dew no he
doesn't he doesn't he strikes me as
someone that would dream that I he's on
a mountain Dew guy come on what do you
think of him
really Mountain Dew I kept dealing with
the jump cuts and everything like I'm
not gonna tell you what kind of I'll
tell ya I'll tell you off there what
kind of kind of guys it's actually very
offensive that's really that's really
[ __ ] up or you say that's really
screwed up man but you accuse me being a
mountain Dew guy what is he of all the
offensive things you know the the PC
ways yeah so pretty cool pretty much
what end up happening was was that I I
just kind of I shed that I became me and
I started I took to Twitter yeah
and Twitter video was an excellent it
was just an excellent way to be me
online something would happen and I
would record a video I'm telling you
dude like the amount of time it my
videos Michael fer that's pretty much
the amount of time it took me to record
that video I just turned it on start
saying something probably laughs because
I said something I caught it and I
laughed because it's hilarious what I
just said there's a lot of my own jokes
because I'm a loser
but but uh but yeah that's pretty much
it you know and that's it and then
people started catching on next thing
you know like I'm being followed by
people and people want to listen to what
I'm saying I'm like what's happening
here
yeah do you consider yourself really
political cuz I've actually from all the
stuff that I've watched I've never heard
you really go directly into politics but
everything you're doing is around
politics well because what our politics
right politics is just the management of
people's that's all it is and I love
people like I said like you know I you
know I got a job I had a job at a
marketing firm back in May and I've
always been interested in marketing
right and in order to be an effective
marketer you kind of need to know people
and of course you know when I say I'm a
marketer people are like oh well I don't
trust what he's gonna say because he's
gonna say whatever is the best thing
that I need you here right and it's true
I completely understand that stigma
behind markers but I'd like to think I'm
a bit more ethical about it but yeah
people is my game Pete
is totally my game and because you know
everything that we do ends up involving
people you know that's how you end up
getting venturing into politics but it's
never my direct Avenue because I'm not
I'm not like I'm not like these I'm not
like sargon of akkad who suspends time
you know reading articles or reading
books on likes on social issues and
stuff like that like I'm a guy that
likes to talk to people and and I want
to know people and let's pillage it yeah
so when you sort of got out of that
phase and you start doing Twitter videos
you start putting up YouTube videos and
people are into it yeah then it sort of
you kind of came in to yourself that
that's what I'm here I mean it's yeah
birth you're observed online was almost
your birth as a as a human again I
thought I felt I felt free I felt free
because it was amazing because I was
being this person that I wanted to be
online and I wasn't seeing repercussions
in real life people were actually
excited they're like yo man we love your
[ __ ] like it's crazy like people were
like coming up to me on this like my
friends like at parties would be like
they like dude yeah watch what you're
doing now and like and we like they
appreciated it you know there's
obviously some people those one guy who
I actually kinda I really love this guy
because he had a lot of we played board
games all the time I love board games
and the strategy element is just
something I love strategy like I love
scheming I think I got Golden Girls clue
in the other room if you're not asked
not not not not those kind of board
games sometime with like Twilight you
are like yeah the stuff were eight not
like what there's this one game that I
really like called Twilight Imperium
okay and and yeah that has like alien
race and so yeah but pretty much you
build the board every time and and you
pretty much pick your role at the very
beginning of every round you can pick a
warfare role or a strategy role or or a
politics role and and when you pick a
politics role you draw to the deck that
changes the game essentially you and you
have to vote based on the influence that
you have and so that's the kind of stuff
I like because I mean one time I won a
game by convincing a guy I was his
friend the whole time I was like I can
yo dude I'm your friend and he was a guy
you're my friend because I'm a nice guy
yeah and I was like I'm not gonna attack
you and I never attacked him but the
best part about it was that he never
attacked me and I left that whole side
completely defenseless
and I pulled up pulled a whole offensive
on the other side and I ended up winning
the game because I took over someone's
home system that's the kind of stuff I
like doing yeah I'm a schemer yeah yo
guys I'm a schemer - key was upfront
about being a schemer is the kind of
schemer that that doesn't want to screw
people over on mass yeah you know yeah I
guess I did screw over my friend it's no
way I mean listen that guy was direct
and indirect warfare with me he wanted
to take me over yeah I was being
defensive and I took him over these are
games like that poo-pooed by the gamer
community Kaymer - are the gamers they
can go both ways I think people love
betrayal people love being the villain
people love trying to outsmart other
people I think that's what the most most
multiplayer games tend to do you want to
outsmart the other person you want to be
able to outs kill them you know I don't
have a check how deep in the gaming
world are you we're doing this you two
bleep thing here I got it's a lot of
gamers on youtube I've started my
channel as a gaming channel so I love
video games video games actually this is
gonna go back to my childhood because I
had a rough childhood right video games
books and movies were the three things
that kept me I would say alive what was
your first system my first system was an
NES the original yeah the NES it was so
sad because my dad was like I'm gonna
get you a Super Nintendo but because I
wanted to play the first Mario Brothers
so bad I was like no no I want a
Nintendo which is the dumbest decision
ever the Super Nintendo was amazing I
know people love Super Nintendo I I was
a Sega Genesis guy which is why this is
oh yeah they're the power I went from
NES to to Genesis I skipped over Super
Nintendo but I know I know you people
you you love it and and you demand that
we love it too but to me Sega Genesis
Sega Genesis to be the change as well
Sonic 2 is one of the best soundtracks
in the game ever you know it's amazing
yeah do you remember the Sonic 2
soundtrack I mean I'm sure I can screen
tails I mean I could I remember oh yeah
it was so good it was it was so good
yeah yeah no but so yeah so yeah you
were big so that was a little bit of
your escape was going to the video game
it was video games books movies like I
said like I would say a majority of my
character or my personality or my
identity is built off of Hollywood
movies
so this whole stuff that's been
happening in Hollywood all the the bad
[ __ ] the me to campaign like Harvey
Weinstein all stuff it's affected me a
little bit I'm just been like [ __ ] all
these people like we're cool people that
looked up to you know like these actors
you know and they're not really that no
one said anything about Brad Pitt yet
though
I love Brad Pitt Brad Pitt is like my
favorite actor what happens when they
come for bread if they come for Brad
Pitt he'll be shattered man I swear I
swear you're Brad Pitt's done something
crazy mmm not beside that we really said
yeah I love that game you know you're
making an interesting point because I
think part of course of course it goes
without saying for the people that have
really done the bad things like
Weinstein it's like of course you got to
go down of course if you rape somebody
or of course all of that chance trailers
without saying yeah but you're making an
interesting point about something that I
think is happening at a broader sense
right now which is that it seems like
all of our institutions are crumbling
right in front of us like the whole
Trump thing as the has the political
machine crumbling the media is crumbling
right in front of us mostly by its own
doing Hollywood now is starting to
crumble and I think that's why people
are turning to people I guess so it's
actually kind of cool for us and it's I
guess it's a little bit of pressure to
write like to do good work well to do
good work and be good people yeah
because there's a lot of people who I
find that aren't good people that's sort
of and that's the sad part about it you
know there's some the the crazy thing
about what we do is we have this
opportunity right to connect with people
you have this opportunity to connect
with someone right now that's watching
at this very moment and be like oh my
god that speaks to me and there's people
that are gonna go ahead and incite
hatred with their voices and those
people they're gonna try to go ahead and
bring people together and I've
encountered so many of the people that
are trying to do like the former yeah
it's insane you know like people like
tarik mushy people like Richard Spencer
these people are only around to [ __ ]
with people yeah Terry called me away
the president this I think yesterday I
mean that guy was dreary joisting he was
so excited for me to be on Twitter so
excited you know what's so funny about
tarik all right I honestly don't even
know who he did the song what was it
bust my ass I wash my ass
[Music]
he's called me call he says Rubens a
white supremacist and all these people
start sending me memes about wash my ass
watch your head yeah I had no idea what
they were talking about oh it was
incredible yeah yeah Tariq was a rapper
before you know it shriek was a rapper
and he pick it here and pickup artist
and then he was like you know what
pickup artist game it's not making that
much money oh I know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna race bait and that makes a lot
of money because the people are really
upset
race is a big issue and it's coming up
over and over again as people's voices
start to elevate people who feel like
they don't have a secure identity aren't
gonna go there their opinions about how
they feel about their place in the world
and of course these people are gonna
kind of speak to that you know and
doesn't matter if they're black white or
whatever the crazy thing is that I took
on Tariq and he had me suspended the
first time right so he got me suspended
Twitter at 26,000 followers but because
I'm a marketer I took that opportunity
to kind of flex whatever social contacts
I had and of course they are down
because it's a very mutually beneficial
thing because they get to talk [ __ ]
about Tariq and talking [ __ ] about Tariq
is instant cloud and and and the best
part is that is that you know Tariq was
still trying to fire at me and every
time you try to fire me I spend it and I
boosted way past my original follower
count we didn't within two weeks yeah
but that's what these guys do all the
time right I mean that's why it's I
always think it's like it's hard to
gauge exactly what the level of the
country or the world is like right now
cuz you've got so many bad actors that
people you were talking about for who
just want to revel in hate and get more
followed yes cuz they hate ya and then
you've got some of the good guys and I
like to think we're kind of in that mix
of the guys yeah I definitely thought
it's it's a lot more work to be a good
guy yeah because you're constantly
because these guys who've been like
spurring this level of hatred
you know they they've kind of made this
environment which everyone
and it doubts people's motivations yeah
and so people are honestly darling
motivation people like don't trust Bonta
King because he's martyred this person
in a chat or something like that like
it's like [ __ ] like that yeah and
it's annoying it's really annoying to
have deal with but I think I think that
that's just noise
and that was my problem like I was it's
very hard for me to ignore the noise
because I built my brand on be able to
connect with people right and I love
talking to my followers I found that
like out of the 46,000 followers I had I
felt like the majority were people that
I would love to live in the community
with you know and and so anytime anyone
tried to engage me I was down to engage
them especially if they saw they were
following me because sometimes I'd
actually go to see if someone was
following me and if they were giving me
criticism because I want criticism I
want people to tell me if I'm doing
something wrong so I can know if I can
correct it based on like research right
and yeah and and pretty much what I'm
happening is you know I we're gonna get
we're now we're getting to when I got
suspended a second time but yeah let's
do the shift there so so I didn't
realize that so you had a mini
suspension at first not - you didn't
know that right no I guess I saw you I
don't know that I knew about a first one
so so that was when the first one was
streaking shade that happened June right
before VidCon like literally right
before VidCon okay so that probably was
right about when you were coming on my
radar in the first place so okay so that
was the first one yeah then you get back
on hey how does that go
Twitter sends you an email saying all
right well how literally is is like it
was so funny I was at this thing called
mural fest in Montreal it's when we have
a whole street just decorated by
graffiti artists you know and I was I
sent tarik of IDEO and I was like hey
Tariq how's it going yo listen we've got
plenty of people here where black people
we got we got Asian people we got Brown
I was chilling I was having a good time
I was pretty much trying to remind them
that like the world is like full of full
of happy nice people and so that got me
suspended instant after I sent that
video got suspended they gave me gave
you cause the suspension yeah yeah and
they hang me went on to post about how I
was harassing black Twitter which is
like crazy
they're asking black Twitter dude okay
so that happened so that was the first
thing and then and now coming to the
second one this is crazy and do you know
what happened to the second one you
haven't
I'm not totally sure okay you ready for
this yeah there was a dude and some
random dude the guy had like 15
followers I'm giving him credits because
because I know he's a human being I was
like you know what I'm gonna try talking
to him he was being really annoying and
at some point he said your followers are
just full of like you know fascists and
and hateful people and I was like I was
like that's not true first of all I talk
to my followers very often and so I
quote tweeted him I said yeah I was like
look this guy is he's projecting he
thinks that all my my followers are
goblin so I'm like look I gave him a
goblin name his name is GrubHub yeah
everyone give GrubHub a hug and I said
give him a hug right I can see where
this is going okay and all my followers
went in and they actually gave me the
rule hugs they were like here you have a
hug you feeling bad we get it it's
screwed up you know Bunty Kings not your
enemy and someone reported that for
targeted harassment that's it 46,000
Polar's gone so they only give you two
strikes they gave me saw the two strike
situation this is literally uh well no
it's not about like some butt strikes
like I made a new account I got
suspended Oh a suspension is permanent
by the way on Twitter call them
explosions or exile or something like
that you know it's really just uh yeah
so the first account I had an account
with 26,000 followers
gotcha actually start from zero again
bought up to forty six thousand
followers gone now man I mean see it's
so interesting because I know a lot of
people are watching this that probably
aren't too into the Twitter world or
whatever and they're like why are they
wasting time talking about this or like
this seems like so inside re or oh poor
guy loss is following on Twitter yeah
but there is something very culturally
relevant yeah I mean it brings up all of
these things about about what private
companies can do and that we opt in on
all this stuff about all the issues
around free speech and how they
selectively because we know that there's
plenty of people like Tariq who's who's
constantly harassing people online I'm
four I mean let everybody harass
everybody I don't really care as long as
they're not you know directly calling
for exactly but it does that's why I
don't want people to think this is - I
hope people don't think this is -
insider e because it is relevant to
people like you being able to actually
get your voice out well I mean they
handicapped you Twitter grew my channel
yeah totally did my channels had a slump
for sure since you know I you know I
like I mean I I'm not I'm not getting as
many views as I was when I had my
Twitter account
then say to you you can't create a third
account now I mean you can create a
third account and I could I could go on
right now like I could you know write
out for this interview just go ahead and
just pop on create a Twitter account but
do I want to
I mean look dude I I built up an account
to 26,000 followers first got that
eliminated all right whatever I was like
you screw it
VidCon is happening I wanna be able to
connect with my friends at VidCon make
another account and it was gonna be fun
46 thousand followers later gone again
and it's like it's like how often am I
gonna have to do that you know I'm not
gonna be verified on Twitter anytime
soon because I don't have the right
political agenda yeah you know because
you know they root they removed Richard
Spencer's verification and moved all
these people's right verifications and
you know I don't like Richard Spencer he
should be verified he is switch expense
right verification has nothing to do
with endorsing Polly it has nothing to
do with it is the ability to find the
exact the person that you're actually
looking for but they also get a free bit
of a fee of better I mean your verified
right ah yeah don't ask how I managed to
pull this well no I mean it's obvious
why your verified that's totally okay
but but the thing is that at the end of
the day but people would verify status
are able to kind of do a little bit more
they they don't get hit by by reports as
much as someone without a verified
account right I mean I guess you get a
little more leeway in that you do in
that they see that some celebrity or
politician or media person could
publicly attack me and then I can attack
them so it's not like targeted see
that's the weird thing to me it's like
you can have very few followers and
still be targeted harassment of somebody
else very easily you could spend plenty
of trolls do this all day long just
targeting me to our I don't care okay I
can mute them or whatever it doesn't
matter but the idea of targeted
harassment as a reason to boot somebody
like you it doesn't really make sense in
the way the Twitter work it really does
everyone's targeting people all day long
with retweets of I you see what this
schmuck said and yeah this one and that
that's it's Twitter's built on that it's
built in harassment it's built on target
right and it's ad because you know what
like I would say that my place was one
of the the my twitter was one of the few
few places that actually encourage
people to have a conversation yeah well
what I really liked about your Twitter
was that for all the people that I
follow that now you know like my
timeline has become a headache and I
think most people feel this it's like
more of this more of that Trump this
Trump that like you were just
at least doing something different you
know I mean sitting in your bathroom
screaming about something about
something doing something that like you
were the tough one of the few people
that I could watch and I'd be like oh I
know something interesting is gonna
happen here I'm not gonna be pissed yeah
yeah you leave my videos pissed yeah you
have to be really you have to be really
upset with life to leave my videos
pissed so so what do you think is the
answer to this as now as now someone
that's creating on YouTube so you're in
a similar situation as you were on
Twitter what do you think the answer is
cuz there's places like Praeger you and
I really like Dennis and I've done
videos for you they're in a lawsuit
right now with YouTube over restricting
videos and things like that the
libertarian side of me always says don't
get the government involved in this and
yet I know we're all in this weird
precarious position but where do you
follow that
I'm honestly trying to really fall back
to doing local [ __ ] this is this is
really interesting because a lot of
people I find that we connect with are
people that are involved in the the the
gathering of global power all right
we're in the pursuit of power I know you
don't meet you may not want to admit it
but we are I think I'm in with you I'm
definitely in okay we're in the pursuit
of pursuit of power as youtubers we want
influence over people we want to be able
to go ahead and say something and have
it heard and have it you know we want
people to listen to us because we feel
like we can make some kind of impact in
the world right that's the nature of
YouTube I would say and the nature of
social media in general people that
really grow on social media and what I
was doing on Twitter was I was really
attaining a level of I mean I was
getting millions of impressions a day
mm-hmm it was a great time you know like
I was interact with more people that I
ever did before ever in my life right
you know and and but but these people
were scattered throughout the world
there's some people in Denmark some
people in the UK some people in
California some people in Texas doesn't
matter they're all over the place right
and and I felt like I was really kind of
avoiding connecting with my direct
reality you know because I had already
built my my network of people in real
life didn't feel like I do
they're always give me around it took it
for granted but it's it was really about
kind of falling back and and and
reconnecting with with my community I
think that's really was
what's coming down to I'm like trying to
I still I'm gonna be present in the
global skill because I want to actually
connect with people on YouTube I want to
make some more videos and talk about
things that provide my opinion but I
think that the focus has really shifted
more on on really bringing my city up to
the standards that I thought I thought I
believe in yeah it's usually because I
love that on a personal level I love it
because it's obvious that you're telling
me the truth and it has meaning to you
but on the political level I love it too
because that's what people need to be
doing is stop thinking that the federal
government whether you're in the United
States or Canada or elsewhere stop
thinking that just bureaucrats somewhere
else are supposed to rule your life no
we're supposed to really you have to
rule your life and more importantly
you're gonna look at your neighbor on
your left and your right and you have to
make sure that they're okay because if
you're surrounded by failures you're a
failure yeah
it's just that simple you know it's
funny I don't know if you notice when
you so people know that my Studios in my
home my we have new neighbors next door
and their dog has been barking like
crazy a giant like husky barking from
8:00 a.m. to midnight every day and it's
like I was somebody came over it was
like Milania you complain to the city or
whatever I was like what an odd first
knee-jerk reaction yeah like first I
they're not around a lot for whatever
reason so I've been meaning to just say
hi to them I haven't even met the people
yet but just say hi and be like you know
I love dogs I don't want you to I want
you to do it no no of course not but
like you know your dogs literally
barking all day long maybe something's
wrong with the dog but ya callin for
help but I just thought that the my
friend who came over and said that I
call the city it's like that that weird
thing of like we're gonna sort of get
all of our resolve ourself they give it
to the government no stupid scary it's
it's not scary it's it's [ __ ] dumb
we've been we are actually [ __ ] at
this point the amount of it's insane
that the amount of communication that we
have in this world right and we don't
want to apply it we don't apply the most
elementary level communication if we
can't apply the most elementary level of
communication which is just like hey I'm
standing in front of you how are you
doing if your dog is barking bro can you
please stop your dog from barking I
don't know wise Barkin I love your dog
would maybe I could babysit your dog
something like that or don't send your
dog whatever yeah you know like instead
of talking about that you know how are
we able to handle masking
like Twitter or Facebook or or or
Instagram anything like it makes no
sense Dave people are completely bonkers
they've they don't want to take
ownership of their lives so instead of
taking ownership of their lives they
look to these IU logs these Ivy logs
that are telling them all the solutions
when the reality is that they're never
gonna be able to get these solutions
because they're currently stuck in their
present reality and they refuse
absolutely refuse to connect with the
people that are directly around them
that's that's pretty much what I've
started to do connect with the people
that are around me my friends my my
family my family my mom and my dad I
know so period time when I didn't talk
to my mom for a year I didn't talk to my
mom for a year I live with my parents I
love my parents right a year I didn't
talk to my mother well while you were
living with while I was living them Wow
how insane is that no now I talk to my
mom every day I go and I give her a kiss
on the forehead I tell her I love her I
give her a hug you know that's the kind
of [ __ ] that I do and this is people
this stuff that people aren't doing yeah
I'm not doing they're not connecting
with people it's interesting getting
some other people to handle it for them
because they're [ __ ] yeah or they're
just screaming about it online because
they're [ __ ] yeah dude we're
surrounded by by [ __ ] there's a lot
of [ __ ] around here yeah absolutely
yeah which isn't a bad thing I love you
Dave my god you're good now like you
it's funny what you're talking about
sort of reminds me of one of the themes
that Jordan Peterson who's you know
ancillary in our world what he's what's
really putting him on the map which is
basically he's saying particularly to
young men just get your [ __ ] together
because that's really what you're saying
to me and that's the through line of
everything you're saying I don't have my
[ __ ] together
I am below the poverty line I'm telling
you man I don't make money on YouTube
fancy sweater like that below the
poverty line trust me
I'm like like this is breaking the bank
I am no I'm not I'm not wealthy my any
means whatsoever in fact started dating
a girl and I told her right away I said
listen I don't have a lot of money but I
want to be I want to be your king I want
to be able to [ __ ] provide everything
for you I'm gonna make it happen but but
I it's not it's not there right is that
where how's that working out
she's totally happy she's down with the
honesty you know
cool but I'll give you a little like a
Reuben report mug when you leave and a
shirt some on the Deep Web
no I yeah no so the the idea is that
like it's not about getting necessarily
a [ __ ] together but it's more about like
you know you can't get your [ __ ]
together but it needs to start from
within like you're not gonna be a
successful businessman you're not gonna
be successful anybody if you're not
gonna be able to be happy with yourself
or be comfortable with yourself and it
being comfortable yourself that mean I
mean that means embracing everything
that is about you right and that also
then then extends to being comfortable
with your direct surroundings you know
so if you're in a situation right and
I'm not saying that this is by the way
once again this is where my privileged
point of view comes from I may not have
these views if I was living somewhere
else if I was living in a place that was
really impoverished or a place where you
know the threat of murder or anything
that was prevalent I may not have these
views but you think that's really
privileged or just reality like I
generally I don't like the word pretty I
know it's a shitty word to use honestly
because it's you use but the reality you
grew up in but that it is it is it and
even though you said before that your
father was successful beforehand and all
that no one probably gave him anything
and I'm guessing his parents probably
didn't have much before that so like
that's why this idea of privilege it
always flipped sort of history on its
head well I'm lucky I'm just really
lucky I'm lucky like I could if I like
that better I like luck we're I mean
yeah yeah I'm just lucky you know like
by comparison to some people I'm doing
way better you know like I see em below
the poverty line but I can afford stuff
I can go out to a bar and have a drink
you know like that's something that the
poorest people can't do so I'm
definitely lucky you know I'm able to
I'm able to be a youtuber while not
making that much money and still
continue to pursue this dream you know
of being a youtuber or being someone
that's connected with the public because
I have the privilege of living with my
parents I mean they're like your mom
died I don't want to I don't want to go
to school I don't want to do this right
now
I want to do this and they're like okay
cool come stay with us did mom and dad
ever give you the ultimatum oh no no but
that person off guard I love I love them
they love me they want me to be happy
they just they just want me to make the
world a bit of a better place they'd be
happy doing that yeah what do you make
of this cool crew that I've seen sort of
all
come together on YouTube so we're
talking what are you talking well well
for example Laci green who's been on the
show before brought you here she's in
the yeah I love how she's her boyfriend
is Chris Regan who love this whole week
of YouTube week um you know I don't you
Derek right I got I got Derek well I got
some black guy Derek Blackman who I
found out his real name's not Blackman
that's just a joke yeah yeah yeah oh
please didn't know that but God Erica
Jacqueline Glenn who's atheist former
former Catholic have rucka who's got a
really interesting story and I really
want to lead to some of the things that
I got from him who else we had Neil
cultic our who's Indian from Australia
great comic like all of these people
they have some difference of diversity
of skin color yeah but but I don't care
about any of that [ __ ] what I like is
that all these people from all over the
somewhat connected we've all sort of
found each other and I think it's
incredibly cool like that we've come
together because of good ideas yeah I
know you're talking about it's easy to
do the bad idea what do you make of this
kind of burgeoning community I think
that there's just as natural evolution
of human society you know we've got this
platform called YouTube right we start
putting our ideas out there we started
using social media and next thing I know
we're bumping two into each other
because ultimately people are going to
be associated with the people that
reflect their values like you could be
my neighbor tomorrow and it would be no
problem whatsoever
I'd be like yo you want to come over for
a drink it would be no issue Yeah right
I had a dog that barks a lot no I don't
I don't have a dog that's totally fine
I'm totally fine and if we did have it
we can work it out we're not probably
not wrong yeah so I mean like that's the
thing right so it's like ultimately we
are associating with people that we
gravitate towards based on our ideals
based on on on what we how we see the
world you know and that's and that
applies to absolutely anyone it applies
to the racists it applies to the crazy
leftists they all gravitate to each
other have you noticed that let you get
into your own echo chamber we're in echo
chambers we're all in a giant echo
chamber that has echo chambers that's
pretty much it we're in an echo chamber
with our MIDI echo chambers pretty much
exactly I mean look they can think about
this right alright so as you tubers okay
we get you get you get millions of views
a month right that's cool how many
Americans are there
there were more Americans than there are
you view getting views a month way more
oh yeah how many there's about 350
million I'm sure I'm sure that I could
walk up to like nobody knows me in my
city I mean people that do know me but
nobody really I mean I can't walk down
the street and I won't get stopped a
bunch of times
you know I could go and I could go into
my city be like do you know who Dave
Rubin is and they'd be like no you
understand like there's like we do have
a lot of influence but we don't have a
lot of influence in the larger picture I
gotta take this on the road to Montreal
I'm not saying they need to do a live
show in Montreal that would be hilarious
I'm not saying that I'm just saying that
essentially the best possible thing is
that is that we realize that we don't
actually have a lot of influence in the
bigger picture yeah we are in an echo
chamber that ultimately that we should
be we should stop freaking out about
things so isn't that though at odds with
what you said which is you want to
influence the world how do you how do
you reconcile those two things you have
to inject yourself in a real life you
have to inject yourself in the
established system so like I mean I've
I've thought about you know like finding
our way to get into the UN I thought
about those kind of things I thought
about finding a way to get into local
politics you know and I've gotten
involved through media ventures I work
with this this this company and in
Montreal called motion Corps and what we
do is essentially we try to like connect
with creators in the area and we've
connected with our local politicians I'm
in a campaign video for our new newly
elected mayor mayor which is crazy first
female mayor in Montreal and now I'm in
a campaign video verse on social media
which is sick so you're saying perhaps
that better than screaming about Trudeau
or Trump every day is actually getting
involved incredible crazy it's just like
it's just like like it's just getting
involved yeah yeah thank you yeah you
got it this is vodka by the way oh I
appreciate that I think I've been just
swinging it yeah you know I want to
finally get to the truth I want you to
open up you know what I'm saying so we
knew we had to listen finally get to the
truth you're lying this whole time
you're doing a fine job so we sort of
hit on this a little bit but what about
so some of the frustrations with being a
creator at the moment not even now look
we you you got the boot from Twitter
everybody that I've talked to that we're
gonna release this week frustrated about
and ad pocalypse and all that anything
else that's high on your list about the
frustrations of putting out content away
bit that we do I think it ultimately
comes down to being frustrated with
though it III put too much credence in
in in the opinions of people the
opinions of people that shouldn't they
like when someone says something really
shitty about me you know because I
because I understand that that's a human
being on the other end it bothers me it
actually hurts me that someone said
something rude about me because I'm
giving them the opportunity I'm
humanizing them but they haven't
humanized me yet mm-hmm so that's
something that I have an issue with it
goes way beyond monetization for me like
monetization like I wasn't making that
much money on YouTube anyway I've never
been doing this for I mean I started
doing it for money and then I realized
like doing it for money makes you
miserable and then I was like I gotta
start doing this for you know me and for
other people and for wanting to make the
world a better place or how I want it to
be yeah and so that money left the
windows so from you anytime I get
dumontet I just go and choose you know
request request monetization or request
whatever it is that's it that's it just
wait so I've just been doing that and so
I haven't been really too bothered by
that but literally just this morning I
happen to check our you know the are
like hidden reuben report email that
gets all the youtube correspondences and
they we requested a review of something
that we put up three years ago so the
real question the review must have been
from three years ago yeah they finally
said yes today three years later it's
like that's crazy
it's an only imagine the amount of
people that are sending a review
requests their way though I'm the only
met it can only imagine it must be
insane the amount of workload they're
under it's funny because I feel like I
feel like you're probably gonna get you
probably had a bunch of other people
that are like yeah [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
going on I'm like not I try to
understand because I know people that
were getting you too but I know how much
they love their platform and I know how
much they want to make it a better place
yeah and I'm honestly dude like you know
and just being on Twitter and not not on
Twitter which I'm thankful for actually
because I I don't ever want to come back
to Twitter yeah
it's not that it sucks because like I I
like I like to interacting people like
you I like to interacting with my
friends on Twitter but I just need to
so- dude it was so negative there's
people there with like 40,000 followers
that nobody's ever really gonna know in
real life but they're just pushing this
crazy hateful agenda i'm just really
annoying you know it's funny right
before
sat down or right before we went live
you sort of half apologized to me for a
tweet that you sent me and I think it
perfectly encapsulates what you're
saying so I it stefan molyneux on and we
talked a little bit about race and IQ
but those related something that tom's
solid covered in one of his books and i
was like i was like i would be really
interested to see what Stefan Molyneux
has to say to this yeah I just call it
and then some people can like oh well
there we go you find your cited trumpty
I'm like no more trying Trump Dave I'm
just asking him literally what stefan
molyneux would think i don't dislike
stefan molyneux I think he's very
well-spoken dude is it dad I don't think
that bad people can meet dads well
people well you can't man I mean what
you want to mean I'm just like he looks
like he has dad his proud father and his
like thing and is a bio on Twitter can't
be a you can't be a bad guy that way I
don't know so it's funny though because
some people I saw in that little
exchange some people were trying to get
you to fight with Stefan some people
wanted you to fight with me I'm gonna do
right and when you said and I responded
your tweet I was like yeah when I have
Thomas on this is of course this is one
of the things that I'm gonna talk to
them about but it's that so you know
weigh everything that you're talking
about here for the last however many
minutes has led you to now being off
Twitter where you're back in the real
world you don't want to get back in
there's sort of a there's like a beauty
a beauty and an irony or something
that's interesting with the situation
you're I miss talking to people all
right but I don't miss the hostility
that's President on Twitter the platform
is just built on hostility and it's and
it's and it's just sad it's sad because
they've also given too much power to
these losers he's the person that got me
suspended the second time yeah is an
absolute loser alright if this guy I
don't know I'm never gonna meet this
person in real life you know he had a
thousand followers or something like
that he was not not I've never seen him
I never interacted them before so
getting to my previous question do we
need alternatives like what's the
alternative do we need blockchain
Twitter's and I think I think that
people of that I think that Twitter on
its own is not the is not the best
platform for communication I think that
if you want to talk and you want to be a
respectful person you want to be a real
human you can go to Facebook and then if
you want to just go ahead and showcase
parts of your life you can go to
Instagram and both Facebook and
Instagram by the way in terms of like
and we're gonna go and talk just like
touch a little bit on marketing here are
way more
Taizo Belen terms of their engagement
because the engagement on Twitter is a
lot is a lot of fluff a lot of anonymous
accounts that don't really matter to a
brad ver ties errs right but Facebook
and Instagram are like then engage them
there is raw anytime you like interact
with a video on Facebook you can choose
hahaha you can choose like angry so the
engagement is much more real and of
course people have associated their full
names with their Facebook counsel
anybody interacting there on Facebook
you know their full name which is way
more of a how valuable to an advertiser
way more valuable
sometimes I grow that that's pretty much
like it's a challenge not being bad
enough twitter has been a challenge and
I need to kind of be strategizing the
kind of like I can't go I can't use
Facebook like I use Twitter I have to
use it very differently all right so
where do you see all this going for you
I honestly see this I have no idea
I wish I could answer that question I
guess I guess ultimately no I'm gonna
continue doing social media I'm going to
continue like trying to like connect
with them as many people as possible but
ultimately I see this kind of coming to
a point where I get to reconnect with my
direct reality you know because I was my
friends my best friends
their names were Brad and Jason two
amazing people that I've known for over
fourteen years of my life these people
were seeing me at parties and had be on
Twitter dude at a [ __ ] party I'm
looking at my phone I'm like responding
to people who I'm probably never going
to meet you nice to meet some of these
people but like never gonna meet them
lately
right and and so now that that's gone
it's allowed me to reconnect with people
in real life do you feel clearer I mean
like your mind cuz I know for them yes I
took off yes I felt better yes it felt
amazing Twitter it was Twitter's [ __ ]
toxic I haven't left social media I'm on
Facebook and I'm on Instagram
I'm posting my own Instagram anyone
replies mine Instagram I reply to the
Mac most the time but it's Twitter it
was absolutely toxic it allows people to
be anonymous and of course with an
annuity is this beautiful thing where
someone can really be real you know so
these I met plenty of anonymous people
that said really nice things because
they felt like they could really be
themselves but the only thing I would
approach may be to be if my audience is
listening can't go on address my organs
address your ratings if my audience is
listening ya know and my Mutual's are
listening right now
the best thing I could say is that
people who really align with my
ideologies with people who align with my
way of living to just join just jump
back on Facebook because I don't think
that you should have a problem because I
don't have a problem in real life with
my opinions
I may not people may not necessarily
agree with everything that I say but
they're willing to talk to me because
they know I'm not a psychopath so if you
can align with my ideologies then you
can jump on facebook and gentlemen
Instagram you can be yourself online I
sense you're basically a live in let
live liberal you think that's a fair way
I am yes I am definitely that person but
it's you know I'm I'm also a lot of
person that I want people to be honest
and understand that the level of
influence they have so when I see people
when I see people abusing that when I
see people putting on fake news it
pisses me off too it's not it's not
right it's not a date they know what
they're doing
I know whenever I treat something
whenever I tweet something by the way
I'd always I'd always use the right
words because I knew what words are
gonna hit mm-hmm all right and of course
I would kind of craft that within a
message that I aligned with
wholeheartedly so I wouldn't be called
out for being disingenuous but I know
there's people out there right now that
have a lot of influence that really are
very disingenuous about their message
because they know that it's gonna get
them further in life they know that it's
gonna go ahead and and and allow them to
to get the most most people pissed off
and a lot of it has to do with these
these race-baiting articles that we see
in salon and stuff like that yeah and
the only thing I can really recommend to
people when they see that kind of [ __ ]
is just to ignore it because most normal
people don't care about that [ __ ] they
don't care they don't even know that the
conversation is happening but I like to
mention the intentions thing because I
think that really is the the heart of
what's going on here yeah some people
are basically good actors I'm basically
a good actor I I will make mistakes
without question I try to correct them
when I do yeah I will talk to people
that maybe have had a bit of a nefarious
past you may have murdered somebody for
all I know but I wasn't anything to
anyone I bought an anti-semite though
before a grantee weekend Montreal yeah
what was that like it was I was waiting
yeah I had him up against a window and I
was head-butting him yeah made it
physical first I made a physical first
he was actually doing on the punching
I was I was I was not it's not the right
it was not the right thing to do
hundra's i'm not the right thing to do
but he was being very very disrespectful
to a woman and and and as a woman that
was being courted by one of my friends
and so I punched him in the mouth and
then and then I pushed him know I guess
who I know and I started headbutt him
and then a cop split it up and the cop
was like you look like a nice guy I'm
gonna let you go but but like get this
over with and then escalated from there
ended up in the hospital later well
listen since the D monetization is tough
are you looking for a little extra work
is maybe a bodyguard or something I
can't be head-butting people and mess up
the hair it was funny uh he's funny
walking around with Chris and Lacey you
know like just I was talking them about
stuff I'm not gonna go into details but
it's funny because like I was dying
there I'm like they it's a I almost I
told them I said listen anyone ever said
anything to you or try to do something
to I beat the [ __ ] out of them I don't
care like I just I I know I don't I
don't want I don't want anyone hurting
you guys you know like that's kind of
thing so but I don't know that's not I
really try not to be yeah but you have
this inner peace inner peace and beauty
and all this and then it's also couched
in I mean I do that I get in fights all
the time I was the most suspended kid in
high in high school I used to be in
detention all the time you know Madrid
school because kids would always be
trying to pick fights with me and I'd
always try to fight back and and yeah
but no I don't haven't had the need to
fight anyone in in over a decade so it's
beautiful yeah and I don't want to I
always told people I said the next time
I fight someone let me kill them and I
don't want to do that ever
it's kind of crazy that you're ending
this with a threat to me so man no I
don't want to do that I really don't
want you think it's not it's not
something that it's just more about like
it's not like there's no need to fight
anyone you can deal with everything
through words you can just talk to
people understand that like I'm here to
just help you out I just want I want to
make sure that you're comfortable
alright if we can understand that we
will bond want to be comfortable then
that's cool but on it the only time
you're ever gonna get into a fight again
is is if is if that's like you know
things are bad yeah you don't need to
fight anyone I don't exactly I need to
fight anybody yeah plus Star Wars is
coming out this week I want to give my
right frame of mind when I go there and
yeah yeah that's a lot yeah well listen
man this has been a pleasure
you know you
as I said you were the last one in in
YouTube week even though this is
actually the first one but I think we I
think we kicked it off the right way do
you feel we got to where this is a great
interview do you have fun
I did okay I hope the audience had fun I
think they did yeah we ended on a bit of
a darker note there I just want to
divide we got my I just want to let
people know that that is not my mo I
just want to chill please don't fight
each other love each other it's so easy
it's nice hugging is so nice
we undetailed when your first night we
did hug each other it was a warm hug
yeah it was yeah you want a hug again
absolutely not right now cuz we Mike's
it you know it really though it's been a
pleasure I love what you're doing and
I'm going to donate your patreon no
you're not yes stop that so there's
nothing you can do the holiday season
I'm gonna donate to your patreon and
everybody else for more of Bunty King
you can follow them on youtube.com slash
mr. Bundy King oh and check out this
preview of what else is coming up on the
reuben report this week coming up on
reuben report youtube week I did not
[ __ ] my pants to make that like that in
the description okay Jaclyn's I'm not
sure man you don't have to be an
intellectual juggernaut to get a lot of
things I'm not the smartest guy I just
like to think things through and
sometimes I'm wrong but at least I'm
trying
that was a huge stigma attached with
anyone who was like a youtuber was like
oh you just do cat videos I like right
you just a prankster you can't do
anything we can create professional good
content well the first time I heard hi
my name is slim shadey on the radio I
was 11 that just like I was like that's
it like I'm doing this forever